est ce que tu penses je continuerai à te
plaire si je n'ai pu que c'est une
question que je pose à elle à moi aux
autres est-ce que j'éprouverai toujours
un semblant de satisfaction lorsque je
me regarderai dans la glace depuis
maintenant dix ans j'ai commencé à
perdre mes cheveux
c'était un super à tous mais aujourd'hui
je peux plus compter dessus
je pense même qu'on peut dire que c'est
une faiblesse c'est fou parce que les
dix ans jamais j'aurais pensé les
bernois se mes cheveux ils sont là pour
toujours quoi on est une team donner
c'est donner reprendre c'est voler leur
âge pour beaucoup de choses apparemment
pas pour les cheveux dans cette vidéo je
ne parlerai que de l'alopécie masculine
ce qu'on appelle communément la calvitie
ou la bonne grosse calvasse du coup je
parlerai pas du fait de perdre ses
cheveux suit un traitement ou un choc
psychologique ou encore de l'alopécie
féminine car ce sont des choses que je
n'ai pas vécu lorsque vous savez que
vous allez devenir chauve il est
possible que vous ayez cette même
première question que beaucoup
est-ce que vous pouvez être chaud et
plaire plaire aux autres mais surtout à
vous du coup vous regardez les
classements des stars hollywoodiennes
chauffe et vous vous rendez compte que
globalement il faut être quand et musclé
merde
et puis vous vous demandez à quoi vous
ressemblerez donc vous téléchargez des
simulateurs vous tirez les courageux
cheveux qu'il reste devant la glace et
c'est assez rare de se dire oh ça
me battre ou bien vous a brillé tout
petit côté shiny bien chaud là on voit
bien mon crâne c'est stylé un jeune qui
était vraiment pour rien du coup je les
ai moi même essayé il ya quelques années
c'était une expérience intéressante mais
pas comme je l'attendais je me souviens
d'une soirée dans un bar où il ya
quelqu'un qui me cherchais et pour
l'aiguiller on lui a dit c'est le show
et ça m'a surpris parce que j'avais
l'habitude qu'on dise voilà c'est le mec
qui fait des vannes qui parle de trucs
un peu de philo machin bref j'en sais
rien mais les caractéristiques de ma
personnalité en fait et pour la première
fois mon facteur différenciant une
caractéristique physique
en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que je
n'étais plus un blanc brun barbus c'est
à dire un mec on ne peut plus dans la
norme évidemment ma situation n'est pas
du tout comparable avec beaucoup
minorité qui vivent des vrais
discriminations dues à leur physique etc
moi c'est pas ça de ce dont je parle moi
je parle juste du fait
d'être reconnus non pas pour quelque
chose de nouveau la personnalité mais
quelque chose niveau du physique
mais avant ça sera pas le même ressenti
la même différence si c'est juste une
couleur de cheveux ou si c'est une
couleur de peau mais se passer mon
propos mon propos c'est juste de parler
des caractères différenciant qui sont
physiques ou de l'or de la personnalité
et donc comme j'étais blanc brun barbu
toute ma vie avant cet épisode là en
fait quand on est blanc brun barbu on
confond pas ce que c'est d'être
différencier avec un caractère physique
et c'est ce qui fait je pense que
beaucoup de gens sont hermétiques au
discours de la minorité qui explique le
problème est que ben est plein de gens
qui sont là en mode grâce à air rsi
chill mais c'est parce qu'en fait gars
tu sais pas ce que c'est quoi bon
évidemment ça arrivait parfois vu que
c'est pas très grand on pouvait dire
ouais c'est le mec c'est le petit qui au
bar voilà etc mais là c'était
systématique en fait c'était j'étais le
show j'étais le show est donc c'était
une des premières fois pour moi ou
vraiment j'avais l'impression de ne plus
être reconnu pour mon style mon propos
ma personnalité mais pour une différence
physique et ça a été un petit peu une
révélation
et encore je suis très très loin
d'expérimenter ne serait-ce qu'un
millième de ce que beaucoup minorités
peuvent expérimenter ce que j'ai vécu à
ce niveau là c'est rien même si je suis
chauve demain j'ai encore beaucoup
d'attributs c'est à dire le fait d'être
jeu par blanc un homme d'être valide
bref plein de privilèges en fait qui
font que ma situation n'est pas à
plaindre
voilà j'espère que j'ai compris que je
ne mets pas les choses sur même niveau
je veux juste donner mon témoignage mais
que je ne veux heurter personne
avec celui-ci mais j'en parle quand même
parce que je m'attendais pas à ce que
perdre mes cheveux aboutissent à ses
réflexions dans la même idée des
réflexions que ça a pu engendrer
j'avais pas conscience que mon problème
était en fait un problème assez courant
chez les femmes en discutant avec elle
voilà ce qu'on m'a dit ce que tu vis qui
te semble assez dur perso j'ai
l'impression de vivre depuis enfants me
battre contre mon physique et
l'évolution de mon corps est
complètement intégré dans ma vie mes
habitudes et mon jugement
c'est la non acceptation de ma version
naturelle épilation anticernes fond
teint coloration des cheveux blancs
décoloration de poils du visage régime
et cela ne concerne que moi
et j'avoue que j'avais pas pensé non
plus donc non seulement je deviens
chauffe en plus je deviens compréhensif
envers les meufs
j'espère ne pas trop perdre de ma
virilité quand même donc voilà je perds
mes cheveux et tout me le rappelle tout
le temps il suffit que je travaille à
mon bureau que je prenne ma douche que
j'aille au lit je les perds partout
alors c'est généralement par période
mais je vous avoue qu'il ya un petit
côté cherry blossom avec la poésie en
moins dans son livre la vie des douze
césars suis tonus tranquille us nous
informe que l'empereur caligula avait
beaucoup de mal à assumer sa calvitie et
que n'importe qui qui le regardaient
d'au dessus et est soumis à la peine de
mort depuis l'antiquité déjà la calvitie
pose problème à plus d'un homme il ya le
poète au vide qui disait affreux sont
les taureaux sans cornes en terrain sans
herbe est une nuisance à la vue tout
comme un arbre sans feuilles
tout comme une tête sans cheveux et près
de 2000 ans plus tard nous n'avons
toujours pas de vrai remède efficace
contre cette perte de cheveux
alors je les connais pas mal hein j'ai
pas mal travaillé le truc donc je vous
en parlais très vite fait on va pas
passer plus d'une minute dessus mais je
voulais quand même donner mon avis le
minoxidil donc ces notions qu'on
applique matin et soir à ses cheveux ses
traits relou surtout parce que dès que
vous arrêtez en fait vous retombez au
stade où vous êtes censé être le
finastéride médicaments qui marche
relativement bien mais il ya eu quelques
très rares cas de gens qui sont
retrouvés impuissants
donc voilà pas très bandant la micro
pigmentation c'est des petits tatouages
pour faire comme si on avait des cheveux
courts ça pourquoi pas c'est mieux qu'un
dauphin les implants compliqué cher
risque que ça se passe pas hyper bien
très engageant il y en a qui le font ça
se passe très bien
personnellement je suis pas prêt pour ça
peut-être un jour pourquoi pas mais pour
l'instant après y'a les perruques aussi
ça franchement pourquoi pas c'est aussi
l'occasion de tester des trucs un peu
plus cool je vois par exemple je passe
je joue un jeu vidéo japonais et fire
emblem et dans tous les personnages ils
ont des coupes trop stylé et où je me
dis on n'exploite pas assez clairement
notre potentiel capillaire donc avoir
une coupe à la yu-gi-oh ou à la andy
warhol
franchement pourquoi pas ça risque
d'arriver je vous préviens je reviens
juste un instant sur les implants en
fait vous savez perdre ses cheveux
c'est chiant c'est long c'est du stress
et j'ai pas envie d'en rajouter en fait
avec les implants pas de me débarrasser
du problème quoi g
j'en ai marre en fait j'en ai marre donc
je pourrais continuer à aller chez mon
barbier mon incroyable barbie qui fait
un travail formidable et qui à chaque
fois me donne l'impression que j'ai pas
de problème de chute de cheveux mais
d'une certaine manière j'ai l'impression
que juste qui me maintient en perfusion
je pense que le plus à huy ouais ouais
je vous ai dit que c'est un jugement qui
était assez progressif mais
paradoxalement la prise de conscience du
truc et le deuil au final de la perte
des cheveux à quelque chose d'assez
brutale et surprenant ça va arriver est
très différent de sai et donc j'imagine
que voilà ça y est ou pas 1 vous
souvenez jeu déjà passés par ce genre de
phase peut-être que je vais décider de
les laisser pousser
peut-être que je vais opter pour
d'autres solutions comme celle qu'on a
vue un peu plus tôt j'en sais rien je
sais pas lorsque j'étais au népal il ya
une chose que j'ai réalisé c'est
l'impermanence des choses
les moines nous le répéter sans cesse
d'ailleurs j'en parle souvent en live ou
en conférence c'est un concept qui est
vraiment clé est extrêmement important
pour moi
ce concept on porte tous en nous parce
qu'on vieillit parce qu'on oublie parce
qu'on change mêmes parce qu'on perd ses
cheveux
la perte de cheveux c'est une
manifestation flagrante de ce concept
est à chaque fois que ça me contrarie
rats j'essaierai de me rappeler parce
que je pense qu'au final la meilleure
solution
vis-à-vis de moi-même vis-à-vis des
autres et même vis-à-vis de
l'attractivité c'est celle de
l'assomption assumé qui on est et ce
qu'on est votre attitude et votre
personnalité contre
plus à votre style que votre paire de
sneakers vous bien votre coupe avec
contour sénèque l'inde mais philosophe
préféré aurait dit je ne me considère
pas chauffe
je me considère juste plus grand que mes
cheveux et j'aime bien j'espère que
cette vidéo vous a plu elle est un peu
spécial c'est c'était important pour moi
de parler de ce sujet de parler de tout
ce que la perte de cheveux m'avait avait
déclenché chez moi il y à du contenu là
dessus sur youtube mais à chaque fois le
contenu sur youtube sur la perte de
cheveux il est jamais sur l'importance
d' assumer je trouve il est surtout sur
comment les solutions en fait et je
pense que l'une des solutions dont on
parle pas assez basses et l'assomption
c'est pas facile c'est même plutôt dur
je pense et c'est un processus de longue
haleine
peut-être que dans quelques années je
sortirai une vidéo comment assumer ce
truc là peut-être que j'aurais pas
réussi à semer ce truc là j'en sais rien
je ne sais pas du tout mais en tout cas
là maintenant c'est de ça dont je
voulais vous parler
bref c'est pas être juge et j'espère que
ces vidéos vous a plu je suis en débrief
là tout de suite là maintenant sur
twitter switch pour un tv slash cyrus
vance sachez que régulièrement je fais
des lectures par exemple on est en train
de lire l'art d'être heureux en ce
moment de schopenhauer
bref c'est c'est hyper cool en train de
construire une communauté vraiment
bienveillante et hyper cool et on se
marre donc voilà il s'était pas à pas
c'est donc là j'ai suivi tout de suite
si vous regardez cette vidéo au moment
où elle sort mais sinon j'y suis
régulièrement il ya un planning
normalement qui sera sur la page twitter
et que j'essaie de mettre à jour
j'espère continuer à être aussi actif
après le confinement j'avoue que le
confinement m'a donné l'occasion voilà
d'essayer ce genre de choses j'avais pas
forcément le temps avant et là je les
prix et c'est vraiment un plaisir quoi
et en dehors de ça j'espère que vous
allez tous bien j'espère que
ça se passe bien pour vous pour votre
famille et voilà faites attention à vous
faites attention à vous embrasse très
très fort et et c'est un plaisir d'avoir
un espace comme ça où je peux partager
certains de mes ressentis les plus les
plus profonds voilà love peace chao
allons l'appareil dans le script au
moment où je dois me raser la tête et
j'ai peur quoi je ne sais pas où je vais
ça du coup dans la vidéo parce
que c'est bizarre si on a en trop mais
j'ai le coeur qui bat quoi j'ai le coeur
qui bat vite c'est c'est un peu un saut
quoi tu vois tout cas moi je le vis
comme ça je peux peut-être que je suis
trop sensible par rapport aux problèmes
que c'est ou peut-être que au contraire
dans de plus en plus on va prendre
consciencede à quel point ça touche
beaucoup d'hommes et que c'est difficile
pour beaucoup d'hommes j'en sais rien je
sais pas peut-être que dans quelques
années tous ceux qui font des blagues
sur twitter sur lesquels vie si et c'est
ce qu'il charrie bas ce sera considéré
comme des chauvauds fob et que ce sera
genre grappes quoi on sera vraiment pas
cool peut-être j'en sais rien mais en
tout cas là j'ai pu un peu voilà